why do they make them because it says
green and it makes us feel better I know
this isn't a sexy topic and it's not
about the Kardashians so please just
watch it you're gonna learn something
new hi I'm Ari and we're here at
BuzzFeed where we're very green
we have compostable silverware and
compostable cups but what if I told you
these items do not belong in a regular
compost what do you think when you hear
something is compostable I think it's
supposed to break down and you like to
go back to the earth what type of
plastic are you holding do you know
that's a good question
compostable in industrial facilities
which may not exist in your area not
suitable for home composting compostable
plastics can't be put into regular
compost because it doesn't get hot
enough biodegradable plastics need to be
heated up to over 120 degrees Fahrenheit
to break down and you can't recycle it
because it'll harm the quality of the
other plastics they recycle so it goes
right in the trash then why are we
making them well they're not made from
oil so that is good oh ok they're made
from like corn plant materials so are
compostable and biodegradable plastics
really better for our environment and
are any of these materials being reused
let's go to a facility in LA to find out
[Music]
so this is stuff from the blue band this
is the cover
we're the only secondary myrrh from the
United States we recycle as much as we
can that blue bin but because of the way
that technology is today we miss about
10% so a secondary murphy's you just
seen here takes the material that's
missed or the material they choose not
to sort for example bio plastics
in about a month
like are you the only MuRF on the west
coast that's processing bioplastics yes
so you're probably only processing a
very small percentage of the bioplastics
order you're bioplastics go that you
sorry we send them to a facility in East
Coast and they wash it grind it and
they're trying to figure out what to do
with it because they don't have enough
to recycle it most people aren't
recovering file plastics so our bio
plastics even better well it's a Pence's
it's like the chicken and egg we don't
have enough great a system to recycle
them but if we create the system then we
sort it then we can recycle it while
plastics is another way to create the
same product using renewable resource so
if you're tired of our disposable
culture and green washing why not try
some reusable options like bringing your
own thermos for your coffee or your own
bag to the grocery store I know it's
overwhelming it could be difficult just
start small and you can make little
changes I have faith in you okay do you
think we got it yes I look insane no
okay you did it good job every time you
get through a video about the
environment of fairies born